this was the first Christmas in Puerto
Rico since Hurricane Maria devastated
the island local engineers estimate
roughly half of Puerto Rico's 3.3
million people are still without
electricity power is not expected to be
fully restored until May according to
the Army Corps of Engineers but families
work to keep the Christmas spirit alive
CBS News spoke to the Soto family still
living in a shelter after being
displaced by the storm this is Christmas
and it's a tough day from the are my
family we struggle in but don't start we
okay
we are like well Carlos Soto says he
hopes next week will be their last in
the shelter we also spoke with Leslie
Betancourt who flew from Texas to Puerto
Rico to surprise her parents they
celebrated Christmas with a game of
dominoes saying the situation quote does
not power down how festive Puerto Ricans
are of course our thoughts are with
those zillions of Americans so much
still so long after these hurricanes and
they are still suffering yeah of course
and we will be covering their stories in
the days and weeks to come